Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Sorduğunuz zaman insanlara
"Hayattan ne bekliyorsunuz?" diye,
hayattan ne bekliyoruz diye
bu topluluğa sorsam,
farklı cevaplar alacağımı biliyorum.
Çünkü bu topluluk
Türkiye'nin aydınlık yüzü.
Ortalamayı temsil etmez,
ama dışarıya çıkıp
"Ne istersin hayatta?
Hayattan en çok beklediğin şey nedir?"
diye sorsak, insanlar iki şey söylüyorlar.
Yani söyledikleri böyle değil.
Aslında para istiyorlar,
tanınan bir insan olmak istiyorlar,
paraları olursa
ve tanınan bir insan olurlarsa da,
o zaman mutlu olacaklarını düşünüyorlar.
Yani başarı aslında bir anlamda
parayla,
ünlü olmakla
ve güç sahibi olmakla tanımlanıyor
ve bunun sonucu olarak da,
anneler babalar da çocuklarını zaten
bu formatta yetiştirmeye çalışıyor.
İyi bir okula gitsin, mezun olsun,
oradan iyi bir üniversiteye gitsin,
iyi bir işi olsun.
Yani bu "iyi"lerin hepsinin arkasında
"para kazansın", "güç sahibi olsun"
ve "tanınan bir insan olsun" demek var,
bu şekilde kelimelere dökülmese de.
Şimdi ben size başarılı olmakla, kendimce,
mutlu olmak arasındaki ilişkideki
biraz evvel bu hayallerle gerçekleşme
arasındaki köprüyü kurmaya çalışacağım.
Son yıllarda kendi mesleklerinden sıkılan,
kariyerlerine ikinci bir yolda devam etmek
isteyen insanların önemli bir bölümü
psikolojiyi kendilerine iş olarak seçtiler
ve dolayısıyla bir sahte disiplin,
sahte bilim doğdu
psikoloji görüntüsü arkasında.
Hangi sosyal topluluğa girseniz,
bir masaya otursanız 8-10 kişi,
mutlaka bir veya iki tane
yaşam koçu çıkmaya başladı.
Yani dolayısıyla, kendi hayatlarında
zorluk çeken insanların bir bölümü,
başkalarının hayatlarını düzenlemek
gibi bir misyon yüklediler kendilerine
ve çok fazla tekrarlandığı için de,
hiç sorgulanmadan doğru kabul edilen
birtakım sloganlar çıkmaya başladı:
"Başarmak için ne yapmak lazım,
önce kuvvetle istemek lazım."
"En büyük yolculuklar ilk adımla başlar.
Cesaret edeceksin, isteyeceksin."
Şimdi en tehlikeli yalan,
içine doğru karışmış yalandır.
Dolayısıyla tabii ki başaranların hepsi
isteyenlerin arasından çıkar,
ama isteyenlerin çok azı başarılı olur.
İşte sizin bugün sabahtan
bu saate kadar dinlediğiniz
ilham verici hikâyelerin kahramanları,
gerçekten istekleriyle hayalleri arasında
köprü kurmuş olan insanlar.
Çünkü neden?
Buyrun bakın, burası en son olimpiyatlarda
10.000 metre koşusunun final turu.
Yani atletler elenmişler,
elenmişler, elenmişler;
en sonunda da bunlar kalmış, yarışıyorlar.
Ne görüyorsunuz?
Bir şeyin farkındasınız:
Bunların hepsi siyah.
Bu da 100 metre.
Usain Bolt'un arkasındakilere bakın.
Onların hepsi de siyah.
Yani şimdi demek ki buradan
çıkartacağımız sonuç:
Beyazlar yeterince istemiyor,
eğer deminki, yani
istemekle başarmak arasında
doğrudan bir ilişki olmuş olsa,
böyle dememiz lazım.
Tabii ki öyle değil.
Nedir peki mesele?
Eğer orta veya uzun mesafe koşucusu
olmak istiyorsanız,
ACTN3 genine sahip olmanız lazım.
Eğer bu gene sahip değilseniz,
ne kadar isterseniz isteyin,
o düzeye çıkamazsınız.
O düzeye çıktığınız zaman,
motivasyonel faktörler
rol oynamaya başlar.
Yani deminki,
birinci söylemek istediğim şey bu.
"Ya bizim çocuk matematiği sevmiyor."
Veya işte, "Bizimki gece çalışıyor,
gündüz çalışmıyor."
Veya "Şu yemekleri yiyor,
bu yemekleri yemiyor."
Şimdi şunu sormak istiyorum:
Kadere inanıyor musunuz?
İnanıyorsunuz.
Kadere inanmanın
insanı rahatlatan bir tarafı var.
Nedir;
teslimiyet, yani elimden gelen bu,
gerisi yazı.
Peki rahatsız eden tarafı ne?
Madem her şey belli, o zaman
çıkacak cana bunca eziyet niye
diye düşünüyor insan ister istemez.
Peki nerede yazılı kaderimiz?
Şimdi alnımızda dediğimiz zaman,
aslında doğru, yani bir bakıma.
Benim sorum doğru değil,
çünkü bu inanç sistemine dönük bir soru.
İnançlarımız sorgulamadığımız
doğrularımızdır,
sorguladığımız zaman inanç olmaktan çıkar.
Peki bilimsel olarak kader var mı?
Genetik piyangodan
bahtınıza çıkan kaderinizdir.
Dolayısıyla o bir software'dir
ve biz ancak o software'in içindekileri
gerçekleştirebiliriz,
aynen üzerimizde taşıdığımız
cihazlarda olduğu gibi,
bilgisayarlarımızda olduğu gibi.
Dolayısıyla, istemekle başarmak arasındaki
köprünün birinci ayağı bir kere
yatkın olduğumuz bir şeyi istemektir.
"Ya herkes yapıyor, sen de yaparsın."
"Yapanların senden fazla nesi var?"
gibi yaklaşımlar,
son derece yanıltıcı yaklaşımlardır.
Birinci söylemek istediğim şey bu.
Yani işte efendim,
"Açılmamış kanatların gücü bilinmez,
kendini koyver, aç,
bir kere ufuklara at," falan.
Yani bunlar insana duyduğu zaman
iyi gelir de, bunların faydası yok.
Bunların faydası yok
ve dediğim gibi en tehlikeli yalan,
içine doğru karışmış yalandır
ve yalan ne kadar büyükse de,
inanan o kadar çok olur.
O sebeple, başarmak için
bir kere birinci adım
yatkın olduğumuz şeyi yapmaktır.
Başarı iş hayatında da,
kurumlar için, insanlar için de
aslında her gün düzenli olarak yaptığımız
küçük şeyleri tekrarlamaktan geçer.
Burada dinlediğiniz bütün ilham verici
hikâyelerin hepsinde bu vardı.
Her gün düzenli olarak
birtakım şeyleri yapmak,
küçük şeyleri her gün
düzenli olarak yapmak.
Bunun adı disiplindir.
Disiplin, Türkçe'de pek hoş
karşılanan bir kavram değildir.
Güçle, zorbalıkla, baskıyla eş görülür.
Hâlbuki disiplin, tutarlılıktır.
Hedeflerde, ilkelerde,
performans kriterlerinde tutarlılıktır.
Dolayısıyla da insanları başarıya
her gün düzenli olarak yaptıkları
küçük şeyler götürür.
Biri, söylemek istediklerimden biri bu
başarıyla köprüyü kurarken.
İkincisi, başarı sağlamak için
yatkın olduğumuz işi yaparken de
mutlaka zora
ve zahmete katlanmamız gerekir.
Zora ve zahmete katlanmadan,
ki bundan evvel dinlediğiniz ilham verici
hikâyelerin hepsinin içinde bu vardı,
zorluklarla ve zahmetle başarı geliyor.
Şimdi orta sınıf ve üst sınıf ailelerin
çocuklarını yetiştirirken
tuttukları bir yol var,
"Aman çocuğumuz zorluk çekmesin,
bizim yaşadığımız zorlukları yaşamasın"
gibi genel bir eğilim var.
Bu, çocuklara yapılan en büyük kötülüktür.
Çünkü enerjimizi nereye koyarsak
hayat orada gelişir,
biz eğer enerjimizi yatkın olduğumuz
alana koyarsak
orada fark yaratma şansına
sahip olabiliriz.
Yine son yıllardaki bu moda
yaklaşımlardan bir tanesi de,
"Başarmak için ne lazım?
Kendine güvenmen lazım,
kendine güveneceksin."
Psikoloji Amerika'da ağırlıklı olan
bir disiplin olduğu için,
aslında Almanya'da kurulmuş
çıkmıştır 1876'da,
laboratuvarda doğmuş bir disiplindir,
ama bugün Amerika'nın
egemenliğinde olduğu için
dünya da Amerika'nın gerçeklerini
evrensel gerçekler olarak kabul ediyor
ve bunun sonucu olarak da
"Başarmak için kendine güveneceksin,
ne yapacaksın, gözüne bakacaksın
insanların elini sıkacaksın,
kuvvetle sıkacaksın,
postürünü dik tutacaksın,
sesine güvenli bir ifade vereceksin,"
efendim inanmayın.
Hiç kimse bu sebeple başarılı olmaz,
başarılı olan insanlar
kendilerine güvenmeye başlarlar
ve bu özellikleri gösterirler.
Çok basitleştirirsem,
başarılı olmak için ne lazım?
Birincisini söyledim:
Yatkın olduğun işi yapacaksın.
İkincisini söyleyeyim, onu da söyledim:
Zora ve zahmete katlanacaksın.
Üçüncüsü:
İnsan ilişkilerini iyi tutacaksın.
Bu; insanlara kompliman yapmak,
hoş şeyler söylemek demek değildir.
Bu; insanlara sormak ve dinlemektir,
onlara samimi ilgi göstermektir,
anlattıklarının içinden
yeni sorular çıkartmaktır,
kendimizi anlatmaktan çok,
anlamaya çalışmaktır.
Dolayısıyla, yani motivasyonel
konuşmacıların konuşmalarına giderseniz,
işte "Böyle böyle olsan da
kendini böyle göreceksin"
veya işte
"Aynaya baktığın zaman böyle olduğunu
hayal edeceksin"le,
insanlar bir yere varmaz.
Bunlar Çin yemeği gibi yerken lezzetlidir,
ondan sonra yediğiniz hurmalar
bir süre sonra midenizi tırmalar.
"Başarı nedir?" diye bana sorarsanız,
başarı potansiyeli hayata yansıtmaktır.
Potansiyelin hayata yansıtılmasının
önünde ne var?
önündeki en önemli faktörlerden biri bu.
Neye benziyor bu? Meşepalamutu.
Bundan binlercesi
sonbaharda yerlere dökülür,
sonra da süpürülür gider,
ama her palamutun içinde,
uygun bir toprağa düşer
ve uygun bakım görürse,
böyle bir ağaç olma potansiyeli var.
Bu potansiyel nasıl ortaya çıkar?
Bu potansiyeli ortaya çıkartan şey,
yani performans dediğimiz şey
aslında yatkınlık ve bu yatkınlığın hayata
yansımasını sağlayacak olan motivasyondur.
Yatkınlık az gayretle sonuç almaktır,
motivasyon da gayretin yönü
ve yoğunluğudur.
Yatkın olduğumuz işleri daha
kolay yaparız, söylemeye çalıştığım bu.
Peki nasıl hayata çıkar?
Potansiyel baskı altında ortaya çıkar.
Konfor alanından yüksek potansiyel çıkmaz.
Velilerin whatsapp gruplarıyla
yönettikleri okullardan adam yetişmez.
(Alkış)
Biraz evvel dinlediğiniz,
hayat hikâyelerini dinlediğiniz
bütün ilham verici konuşmacıların
hepsinin ortak noktası neydi?
Bir engeli aşmalarıydı.
Türkiye, Amerikan psikolojisinin de
etkisi altında kalarak
başarıyla zehirlenmiş kuşaklar
yetiştiriyor.
Başarıyla zehirlenmiş kuşakların
en ortak özelliği;
başarısızlığı ayıp, yasak,
günah saymaları.
Hâlbuki başarısızlık,
hayatın en doğal parçasıdır.
Her insan başarısız olur,
her kurum başarısız olur.
"Ben hayatımda hiç başarısız olmadım,
ne yaptıysam hep başardım," diyen insanlar
ya yalan söylüyorlardır,
ya akıllarından zoru vardır
ya da buna inanıyorlarsa kibirlidirler,
kibir her inanç sisteminde
en büyük günahlar arasında sayılır.
Dolayısıyla bir kere
şunu kabul etmemiz lazım ki,
başarısızlıklarımız bizi bir yere getirir.
Ben hayatımda hiç başarısız olmadım,
diyen insanlar
sınırlarını zorlamamış olan insanlardır,
çünkü potansiyel
baskı altında cevhere dönüşür
ve bunun sonucunda da mücevher olur.
Kendiliğinden, konfor alanından
potansiyel ortaya çıkmaz.
"Aman çocuklarımız zorluk görmesin,
aman bizim yaşadığımız zorlukları
yaşamasınlar" diye çocuklar yetiştirmek,
onlara yapılan en büyük kötülüktür.
Anne babalara aynı şeyi söylüyorum.
Çocuklarınızı sorumlulukla ödüllendirin.
Evin içinde yaptıkları şeyler
onların görevleri olsun.
İşte sadece bu sebeple,
Hayalini Yorganına Göre Uzat
diye bir kitap yazdım.
Bunun içinde, insanların bu işte
"İstersen başarırsın,
kendine güvenirsen başarırsın,"
"Başarıda 5 Adım, 7 Adım" gibi
kestirme yolların ötesine geçmeleri için
bu biraz evvel anlattığım
bilimsel gerçekleri anlatmaya çalıştım.
Bunlar başarıyla ilgili olanlardı.
Michael Norton diye bir araştırmacı,
laboratuvara öğrencileri çağırıyor
sabahleyin
ve onların elin bir zarf veriyor.
Verdiği zarfta yirmi beş dolar var,
ruh hâllerini yazıyorlar.
Akşamleyin gelip tekrardan
aynı şeyi bildirecekler,
ruh hâllerini bildirecekler.
Zarftaki yirmi beş dolar
araştırmaya katılma parası değil,
onu akşamleyin alacaklar.
"Bu zarfı ne yapacağız?"
"Sadece kendiniz için harcayacaksınız."
Bir başka gruba,
"Bu zarfı sadece başkaları için
harcayacaksınız bu parayı."
Günün sonunda da ruh durumuzunu
tekrar yazacaksınız.
Sonuç?
Akşamleyin başkaları için
harcama yapanlar,
kendilerini daha iyi hissederek
geliyorlar.
Aynı şeyi zaman açısından yapıyorlar.
Bugün vaktini sadece kendini
memnun edecek şeyler için geçir,
bugün vaktini sadece başkalarını
memnun edecek şeyler için geçir.
Akşamın sonunda döndükleri zaman insanlar,
yine başkaları için
bir şey yapmış olanlar,
kendilerini daha iyi hissediyorlar.
Bunun için benim bir formülüm var.
Akşamleyin evde toplandığınız
zaman çocuklarınızla,
okulda öğrencilerinizle,
mutlaka soracağınız soruların arasında
"Bugün kime yardım ettin?"
sorusu bulunsun.
"Kimden yardım istedin?" sorusu bulunsun.
Çünkü yardım istemek güçlülüktür,
yardım isterseniz
insanlar sizden yardım ister.
"Bu hafta kimin başarısına katkıda
bulundun?" önemli bir sorudur.
"Senden daha az şanslı insanlar için
ne yaptın?" önemli bir sorudur.
"Sahip olduğun için kendini şanslı, mutlu,
ayrıcalıklı hissettiğin ne var?"
önemli bir sorudur.
Biz şuna inanıyoruz;
şimdi ben şu salonda değil
ama biraz daha hava sıcak olsa,
elimde bir şey alıp
yelpazelenmeye başlasam,
salonun en az üçte biri
biraz sonra yelpazelenmeye başlar.
Yani davranışlarımız başkalarını etkiler,
sözlerimiz daha çok etkiler.
"Çocuklarımızın hayatı çok zor.
Çocuklarımız çok zor hayat yaşıyorlar.
Vallahi çocukların hayatı
çok zor," dedikçe
çocuklar hayatlarının gerçekten
zor olduğuna inanmaya başlıyorlar.
Gerçekte zor hayatlar yaşayanlar var,
çocuklarımıza bunları anlatmamız gerekiyor
ve bu insanların hayatına
bir katkı yapma sorumlulukları olduğunu
hatırlatmamız gerekiyor.
Sahip oldukları için
mücadele eden insanlar,
sahip olduklarının kıymetlerini bilirler
ve potansiyellerini hayata yansıtırlar.
Sahip olduğu şeyler için
mücadele etmemiş olan insanlar,
sahip olduklarının kıymetini bilmezler
ve her zaman nedeni belli olmaksızın
her şeye kendilerinde hak görürler.
Bir de bu yine psikolojiyi
kendine iş edinenlerin
"Yüreğinin sesini dinle,
içinden gelen sesi dinle,
yüreğinin götürdüğü yere git" gibi
saçma mesajlar geldiği zaman,
bunu sahi zannederler.
İnsanın yüreğinin sesini dinlemesi,
içinden geleni yapması;
yememesi gereken naneleri yedirir,
kırmaması gereken cevizleri kırdırır,
almaması gereken kalorileri aldırır.
(Alkış)
Dolayısıyla hayatın gerçeklerine
bakmamız lazım.
Amerikalı bir matematikçi her sabah,
yani gelecek eğilimlerini pazarlayan
bir iş yapıyor.
Her sabah New York Times
gazetesini okuyor
ve burada
parasız ölüm ilanları yayınlanıyor.
18 ayda 2.000 ölüm ilanını tasnif ediyor,
yani obituaries denilen
parasız ölüm ilanlarıdır bunlar.
Üç gruba ayırıyor:
Bir cümlede kim olduğunu anladığınız
ve büyük boy hayat,
uzun uzun anlatılanlar,
bunlar starlar işte Muhammed Ali gibi,
Sting gibi falan,
Prince gibi pardon starlar.
Bir grup var, tanınmayan insanlar,
ama bir dönemde hayatlarında
önemli bir katkı yapmışlar.
Bu insanların hayat ortalaması 81.
En önemli katkıyı yaptıkları yaş kaç
tahmin edebilir misiniz?
37.
Yani insanlar, 81 yaşında öldüklerinde
44 yıl önce yaptıklarıyla hatırlanıyorlar.
Benim size bu anektodu getirmemin
sebebi üçüncü grup.
Üçüncü gruptaki insanlar
kimselerin tanımadığı insanlar.
4 satır, 6 satır, 8 satır.
Ama hepsinin, hepsinin hayat hikâyesinde
tekrarlayan bir kelime var:
Yardım etti.
Yardım etti, "helped".
Dolayısıyla başarılı olmak için
yatkın olduğumuz işi yapmak,
terlemek ve insanlarla ilişkimizi
iyi tutmak;
mutlu olmak için de, mutlaka başka
insanların hayatına katkıda bulunmak
ve dolayısıyla da dünyada
en iyi insan olmaya çalışmak gibi
gerçekleşmeyecek bir hayalin
peşine koşmak yerine,
dünya için iyi bir insan olmaya
gayret etmek.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)